Thrilled to announce MIT CAST Virtual Visiting Artist Program.
Bringing together three of the most vibrant
artists in the musical scene today.
This year-long program involves a
symbiotic relationship between
the artists, MIT students, faculty, and community.
Exploringnew artistic and pedagogical terrain
offering a tapestry of wide-ranginginteractive and interdisciplinary experiences.
During this challenging periodof COVID, the opportunity for our students and
community to develop personal connections with
artists and people of this magnitude is invaluable.
We look forward to all the deepand enriching opportunities ahead.